according to a report in the verge that
was
kind of lightly sourced zuckerberg might
announce a facebook rebranding during
their connect conference this thursday
the verge uh quoted a source with direct
knowledge of the matter so you can take
this with a grain of salt i'm not saying
that the verge is lying but who knows
you know when
when you only have one person talking
about it not three or four it's thinly
sourced and so this may not be true at
all some people are speculating that it
could be metaverse or meta he seems to
be obsessed with the metaverse if you
haven't heard of the metaverse that's
just the virtual reality space where
users can interact
with digital uh you know avatars and
places
roblox and fortnite would be considered
metaverses it's just kind of like a
science fiction term oculus would
certainly be considered one i don't
consider roblox
minecraft and first person shooters like
fortnight the metaverse i think the
metaverse should be reserved for virtual
reality not 2d
and maybe augmented reality in some way
but
it's something that has never gotten big
if you put aside fortnite which is
obviously huge
it's basically still a pipe dream we had
second life for a period of time we now
have oculus very and i talked about this
on the pod last week
you have a very small base of users on
those devices i find that real gamers
want to play fortnite on a pc or on a
console
and then casual users want to play
casual games on their ipads so who
exactly is the oculus for it's not for
hardcore gamers it's not for casual
gamers
the best we could come up with was
people who wanted to play the golf
simulators and stuff that
maybe was hard to do in the real world
or expensive to do in the real world
skiing golf scuba diving
uh rec room seems to be pretty good
things that make you feel like you're
experiencing some real world activity a
beat saber comes into mind as well so if
you go to the connect conference website
at facebookconnect.com it does have a
very metaversy feel
and the conferences is branded as a
front row seat to the future
great
ar presence and push vr boundaries are
listed as two of the topic sessions
so uh they don't have an ar product but
they do want to push the vr boundaries
this says to me
um that uh there is something new going
on here uh in terms of focus my inside
information is there's a couple of
buildings here in uh the peninsula
over by coyote point in the airport uh
here in san francisco by just south of
sfo
facebook has leased a bunch of buildings
and that's supposedly where they're
working on this and i think zuckerberg's
had enough of dealing with facebook and
things and i think he wants to go all in
on this and it's he knows he's gonna get
disrupted possibly and that's the next
big platform so he is skating where the
puck is going whether that takes another
5 or 10 years or 10 to 20. but he is
very concerned about being disrupted in
the way microsoft was
uh remember he was always enamored with
bill gates as a role model and he saw
gates not get the mobile phone or the
mobile phone operating system right and
he believes that could happen to
facebook what's really happening here
though is i think he's going to rename
the company break it into units then if
you have to take action against the
company you're going to take it against
a specific unit and he
could
i think pull a lariat sergey make
himself executive chair
put a ceo in charge of oculus and put a
ceo in charge of the facebook collection
of apps so cheryl sandberg could run one
group and then somebody else could run
the other he could be executive chair he
could obviously make all the decisions
he's got voting control
but then when they say hey come to
congress come to the eu
come to this country we're gonna pull
your plane out of the air with fire
pilots remember all that drama like he's
going to set foot in on the soil of the
uk and he's going to get dragged to
parliament well you can just say i don't
work there i'm not the ceo anymore i
don't have a day-to-day role i am the
chairman that's exactly what's happened
what sundar is going uh and he will
testify and larry and sergey they do
they actually don't work at google
anymore they work on the big bets which
is what they want to work on anyway
and so they can basically avoid any
scrutiny so
we'll see if congress senators and uh
parliament you know fall for this trick
eventually i think what they should do
is look at has who has voting control of
the shares and that's the person so
if you're a senator or a congress person
you're listening
here's how you do it you can say bring
the ceo but we want to know who's in
control of the board so who controls the
board who has the most shares and the
most voting power that's the person we
want and in that case sorry larry and
sergey sorry zuck
you would get uh have to go and you know
have these tough conversations about
society and the impact these technology
companies have which is a totally
legitimate thing for us to have
conversations about and so
you know the the the article also notes
that the new name is a closely guarded
secret
uh and even senior leadership at
facebook is unaware if you were going to
do a rebranding like this and you were
ceo what you would do is you would come
up with 10 names you would have 10 logos
designed
and you would narrow it down and you
would have your press team write up all
10 press releases
a landing page and then nobody would
know and then you would print it just
like when they um i understand when they
did the luke skywalker cameo in the
second season of mandalorian spoiler
alert if you didn't see it by now it's
your fault um they actually filmed some
other jedi
at in that position
so that even if people got on set or
someone had figured it out they wouldn't
be able to leak it because there were
different endings that were filmed and
they've done that before with other tv
shows will they film multiple endings i
think they did it with that show lost as
well this way people couldn't guess or
couldn't leak more accurately
and then finally in the facebook world
uh internal facebook documents obtained
by the verge it seems like today was
document dump day i think all the
journalists got all of these documents
at the same time and were all agreed to
make their stories come out today that
u.s teenage users have declined by 13
uh since 2019 on facebook this is a big
story i think
and it would match maybe what their
growth issues are
maybe they're keeping everybody who's
above you know 25 years old but they're
just not getting young people that would
vibe with what we see in the real world
with people who are younger liking tick
tock
or maybe
snapchat the internal documents were
part of those disclosures made to the
sec in congress by facebook
whistleblower francis haugen the verge
obtained the redacted versions of these
documents that were received by congress
the specific document in question was an
internal memo sent by a facebook
researcher earlier this year
some more stats from that memo u.s
teenage users were also projected to
drop 45 over the next two years young
adults between the ages of 20 and 30
were expected to decline by four percent
during the same time period this all
aligns
and on average the younger a user was
the less likely they engaged on facebook
this makes sense
the way these are going to work social
networks that is the way social networks
will work
is they will be generational maybe
multi-generational
uh and every generation or two you'll
see them turn over as younger people
don't want to hang out with their
grandparents like if you're on facebook
and you're 19 or 20 years old you're
kind of hanging out with your
grandparents and your parents
it's bad enough you're hanging out with
your parents but you don't want to hang
out with your grandparents that's crazy
and so you'll see multiple arcs of the
life of a social network like we saw for
aol myspace etc the only ones that may
cross over would be something like
linkedin for business because you know
business is still being done there and
how could you not have one
so
quote from the verge
the researcher predicted that if quote
increasingly fewer teens are choosing
facebook as they grow older the company
would face a more severe decline in
young users than it already projected
now this isn't as bad as it seems as we
saw in the revenue older people have
more money to spend they have more
disposable income they make more
decisions about money so facebook would
benefit as people get older because they
have more discretionary spending and
people want to reach those people that
being said for certain categories of
advertising you want young people the
avant-garde
and although they may not spend that
money a lot of people know that if you
become a bmw driver or a mini cooper
driver and they get you for your first
car in one of those cars you might keep
going and buy two or three of those
right anybody out there ever buy two or
three of the same brand tesla beamers
mercedes hondas like some people just
get locked into a brand and
so there's a lot of spending
disproportionate amount of spending
compared to the outcome you know the
output being how much how much you spend
so you may want to get somebody in that
bmw that costs 40 000 they have some of
those entry level models in order to
eventually get them up to a bmw 7 or you
know whatever the
more expensive ones are as they move up
uh socioeconomically with discretionary
spending
as founders investors and executives we
spend so much time building up the
companies and products that we love and
care about but at the end of the day
life is fragile and it can get taken
away at any moment you know that so it
makes sense why people get life
insurance especially term coverage which
is surprisingly affordable why not pay a
little bit each month to protect the
ones you love it's a no-brainer if
you're asking yourself this question
choose ladder ladder makes it really
fast and easy to get covered you just
need a few minutes and a phone or laptop
to apply ladder smart algorithms work in
real time so you'll find out instantly
if you're approved and that's one of the
great things about the service it's just
so quick and easy to use there are no
hidden fees you cancel any time and
since life insurance costs more as you
age now is the time for you to cross it
off your list and make sure it's there
so go check out ladder today and see if
you're instantly approved you'll find
out very quick go to ladderlife.com
twist again l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
twist that's l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
[Music]
twist ladderlife.com to see if you'll
get approved do it now